STICK AROUND.
WE HAVE ANOTHER HUGE STORY, THIS
ONE STARTED 24 YEARS AGO.
>> NO ONE WANTS TO STAND IN THE
WAY OF ARGENTINA, IF IT'S THE
NEXT EMERGING MARKETS DOMINO TO
FALL.
>> WHO IS THAT BRILLIANT BEAUTY?
EVEN MORE BEAUTIFUL TODAY.
THAT IS CHRISTINE ROMANS MAKING
HER CNN DEBUT IN 1999.
SINCE THEN, SHE HAS BEEN AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THIS TEAM AND
NETWORK.
SHE IS ANCHOR OF "EARLY START,"
COVERED SIX PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTIONS, DOT-COM BOOM AND
BUST, SEPTEMBER 11 ATTACK,
HOUSING BUBBLE, FINANCIAL
CRISIS, A GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
IN BETWEEN, IS SHE FIT IN A
WEDDING AND THREE BEAUTIFUL BABY
BOYS, THREE BOOKS AND TEN YEARS
OF 3:00 A.M. WAKE-UP CALLS.
AND TODAY IS HER FINAL DAY WITH
US AT CNN.
I AM AT A LOSS FOR WORDS.
YOU HAVE MEANT SO MUCH FOR ALL
OF US AND TO THIS NETWORK.
>> I FEEL LIKE EVERYBODY HERE,
THESE GUYS INCLUDED, ARE ALL OUR
FRIENDS, YOU KNOW?
THIS HAS BEEN A -- I AM FULL OF
GRATITUDE FOR THE 24 YEARS HERE,
SERIOUSLY.
THIS HAS BEEN AN AMAZING PLACE
TO WORK.
THAT GREEN REPORTER THAT YOU SAW
THERE, THAT WAS THE ARGENTINE
DEBT CRISIS, LEARNING EVERYTHING
I COULD ABOUT ARGENTINA AND ITS
ECONOMY.
I AM GRATEFUL FOR THE PLATFORM.
>> WE LOVE TO TAKE A LOOK BACK
AT SOME MORE OF THAT WORK.
INDULGE US FOR A MOMENT.
EVERYBODY AT HOME --
>> 20 YEARS OF HAIRCUTS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
♪
>> THE OFFICIAL NEW CO-ANCHOR OF
THE "EARLY START" BROADCAST.
>> IT'S MY FIRST DAY.
>> WELCOME, EVERYONE.
CNN'S SATURDAY EDITION ON
FINANCIAL NEWS CORRESPONDENT
CHRISTINE ROMANS.
>> LIVE FROM "NEW YORK, NEW
YORK," THIS IS --
>> WELCOME TO YOUR MONEY, I'M
CHRISTINE ROMANS.
>> UNPRECEDENTED TRAGEDY FOR NEW
YORK'S FINANCIAL DISTRICT AND
WORLD MARKET AND A RARE
OCCURRENCE IN FINANCIAL MARKET
HISTORY AS WELL.
U.S. STOCK MARKETS WILL BE
CLOSED FOR THREE STRAIGHT
WEEKDAYS.
>> CHRISTINE ROMANS ON THE PHONE
RIGHT NOW WITH THE BUREAU OF
LABOR STATISTICS TO FIND OUT
MORE ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON
INSIDE THAT DATA.
>> THIS IS WHAT I CAN TELL YOU
WHEN YOU LOOK INSIDE THAT DATA.
WE WILL GET THE FULL PRESS
RELEASE IN A MINUTE, YOU KNOW,
DIFFERENT TABLES.
>> THIS IS ESSENTIALLY BETTER
THAN EXPECTED.
>> 300 PEOPLE SLEPT AT THE "NEW
YORK, NEW YORK," THE CHAIRMAN
SLEPT ON A COUCH.
A LOT OF UNSHAVEN, UNSHOWERED
GRUMPY PEOPLE WHEN THE OPENING
BELL RANGE.
>> THIS OIL SPILL IS DEVASTATING
IN SO MANY WAYS.
NOT FOR BP'S BOTTOM LINE.
>> YOUR JOB, AMERICAN JOBS ARE
DISAPPEARING FAST.
1.9 MILLION JOBS VANISHED THIS
YEAR.
DO WE EXPECT SHE WILL STAY AT
FACEBOOK FOR THE LONG TERM?
I MEAN, I KNOW SOME OF HER
COMPENSATION IS TIED TO STAYING
THERE FOR A FEW MORE YEARS.
>> IT IS.
BUT SHE HAS PLENTY OF MONEY.
>> FOR SOME FARMERS THEY HAVE
NEVER SEEN THIS MANY POOR YEARS
IN A ROW.
>> DON'T YOU WORRY ABOUT
BORROWING ALL THAT MONEY?
>> I HAVE REAL MONEY FROM CNN.
>> THANK YOU, CNN.
>> FOR THIS REAL MONEY.
WE ARE GOING TO LEARN HOW TO
SPEND IT.
>> THE U.S. STATE DEPARTMENT
TELLING AMERICANS NOT TO TRAVEL
ABROAD AT ALL BECAUSE OF
CORONAVIRUS.
>> MILLIONS ARE WAITING
ANXIOUSLY FOR HELP.
THEY HAVE RENT AND MORTGAGES AND
BILLS TO PAY APRIL 1.
THEY ARE LOSING THEIR JOBS OR
THEY ARE HAVING THEIR PAYCHECKS
CUT.
>> I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
THEY ARE DIGESTING.
THEY ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
JUST HOW THIS ELECTION RACE IS
GOING TO COME OUT.
>> IF GEORGE BUSH HAD LOST, IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN LIKE HIS FATHER
WHO LOST AND IMMEDIATELY THE
ECONOMY STARTED SHOWING SIGNS OF
STRENGTH.
>> WHAT DOES BARACK OBAMA WANT
TO DO ABOUT PROBLEMS IN THE
ECONOMY RIGHT NOW.
>> THERE IS A LITTLE LESS
OPTIMISM ABOUT THE STATUS QUO
AND THEY ARE GOING TO BE LOOKING
FOR SIGNS THAT FISCAL CLIFF
MOVEMENT IS HAPPENING.
>> ZERO MORE DAYS TO THE
ELECTION.
ZERO MORE HOURS, IN FACT.
ZERO MORE RALLIES.
ZERO NOR DEBATES.
ZERO MORE OCTOBER SURPRISES.
ZERO MOREOFRIO VERSE ALS.
>> BASELESS CLAIMS OF ELECTION
FRAUD AS IT TRIES TO CONTEST JOE
BIDEN'S VICTORY.
>> MY GRANDMOTHER'S NAME IS
SHIRLEY JEAN PETERSON.
AND SHE REMEMBERS HER GRANDMA.
>> ASK WHO PAID YOUR PASSAGE?
>> WOW.
THAT'S SO -- YOU HEARD ABOUT THE
TICKET FOR ALL THOSE YEARS.
BUT THEN TO SEE IT.
>> THEY FEEL PERSECUTED FOR
THEIR --
>> THAT'S THE BIGGEST BUNCH OF
NONSENSE EVER.
WHAT KEEPS JAMIE DIMON UP?
>> CYBER.
>> WHAT WAS THE TOUGHEST PART OF
THE CHALLENGE OF CREATING THIS
LAND, ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU ARE
UNDER THE EYES.
"STAR WARS" FANS?
>> NEVER TOO MUCH DETAIL.
>> I WANT TO TRY THEM ON.
>> WHY DON'T YOU.
>> CAN I?
DO YOU MIND?
>> OF COURSE.
>> MUSIC IN GENERAL REALLY HAS
PUSHED THROUGH ANY IDEAS.
>> EVERYBODY IS DIFFERENT.
YOU CAN DEFINITELY BE MY FRIEND.
>> CAN I COME OVER TO DINNER?
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE THEY FOUND
THE VIDEO OF THE CLOSING BELL.
ALL THOSE HAIRCUTS.
>> A LOT OF HAIRCUTS.
GREAT CO-HOST.
>> I KNOW.
JOHN AND I ARE DIFFERENT KINDS
OF ANCHORS.
>> YOU'RE GOOD.
>> NO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> BECAUSE IN THE BREAKS, I LIKE
TO TALK.
I LIKE TO FILL THE TIME AND TALK
AND TALK TO JOHN ABOUT HIS LIFE
AND JOHN LIKES TO LOOK AT
BASEBALL SCORES.
SO WE HAVE THIS THING, I AM
JABBERING AWAY AND HE IS LIKE
LOOKING AT BASEBALL SCORES.
WE GOT ALONG FINAL.
>> SHE INFORMED ME THIS MORNING
SHE WASN'T MY FIRST CO-ANCHOR
BUT SHE WAS MY FAVORITE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I'LL TELL YOU THAT UNTIL IT'S
TRUE.
>> THAT'S ACCORDING TO CHRISTINE
ROMANS, WHO ALSO REMINDED ME OF
A STORY FROM ONE OF OUR FIRST
TRIPS ON THE ROAD WHEN WE
ANCHORED FROM THE FIELD AND SHE
WAS GOING OUT WITH THE CREW FOR
DRINGS BEFORE THE SHOW AND SHE
IS LIKE, COME ON --
>> DRINKS BEFORE THE SHOW?
>> WE HEARD THAT.
>> IT WILL BE A GOOD TIME --
GOOD TO HANG OUT, GET TO KNOW
PEOPLE.
SHE CLAIMS I SAID, YOU KNOW, I
DIDN'T COME HERE TO MAKE
FRIENDS.
>> THAT'S WHAT HE TOLD ME.
I WAS LIKE, OH WOW, I GOT A LOT
OF WORK TO DO ON THIS GUY.
>> OKAY.
SO ROMANS RIGHT, FOR, LIKE, WE
ANCHORED "EARLY START" FROM FOUR
TO SIX FOR 17 YEARS TOGETHER.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND MOSTLY WHAT I REMEMBER
ISN'T THE NEWS.
IT WAS LIKE A TWO-HOUR
CONVERSATION ABOUT OUR KIDS, WHO
DO THE SAME THINGS, THE PEOPLE
WE KNOW WHO ARE ALL THE SAME.
WE ARE THE SAME AGE, ALMOST.
AND JUST HOW WONDERFUL IT WAS TO
BE WITH SOMEONE WHO I ENJOYED SO
MUCH.
>> OH, THANK YOU.
>> FOR LONG.
IT'S THE ONLY THING THAT MADE IT
REMOTELY PALATABLE BECAUSE IT'S
SO EARLY.
AND THE THINGS THAT I LEARNED
ABOUT YOU, I MEAN, CHRISTINE
ROMANS IS, YOU KNOW, WHO --
SMART IS THE NEW RICH, AVAILABLE
IN BOOK STORES, THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL FRENCH MAJOR IN
FINANCIAL JOURNALISM.
RIGHT?
>> SHE IS GOOD.
>> SHE IS IOWA'S FAVORITE CHILD.
THERE IS HERBERT HOOVER AND
CHRISTINE ROMANS.
I KNOW THE CONCERTS SHE WENT TO
IN IOWA.
I KNOW THE PIZZA STORE WHERE SHE
WOULD SMOKE CIGARETTES IN THE
BACK IN IOWA.
>> DO NOT SAY THAT STORY.
>> I HOPE YOUR PARENTS ARE
WATCHING.
AND I FEEL SO LUCKY THAT I HAD
THAT AND TO KNOW YOU, AND THOUGH
YOU CLAIM THAT I SAID I DIDN'T
COME HERE TO MAKE FRIENDS, TURNS
OUT THAT BECAUSE OF YOU, I HAVE
ENDED UP WITH A REALLY, REALLY
GREAT ONE.
>> OH, THANK YOU.
>> AND CO-ANCHOR, WHATEVER, BUT
YOU'RE A GREAT FRIEND.
>> THANK YOU.
THAT'S A WONDERFUL THING ABOUT
THE GRATITUDE I HAVE FOR THIS
PLACE IS THAT WE ARE ALL
FRIENDS.
LOT OF THE GUYS ON THE CAMERA
CREW, LIKE I CALL THEM MY OTHER
BROTHERS.
THEY REALLY ARE.
I HAVE KNOWN THEM SINCE I WAS IN
MY 20s.
I WAS SINGLE IN MY 20s, WIRE
SERVICE REPORTER WHO WALKED IN
THE FRONT DOOR AND LEARNED TV
FROM ALL OF YOU GUYS.
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
>> WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
THINGS THAT WE LOVE ABOUT YOU.
>> WE WERE SOBBING ON THE PHONE.
>> WHAT WE NOTED MOST, WHAT
BERMAN ALLUDED TO, WE ALL FEEL
WHAT A WONDERFUL PERSON YOU ARE.
YOU BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER
BECAUSE OF YOUR KINDNESS,
EMPATHY AND YOU ARE SO GENUINE,
AND I ADORE YOU AND I WILL MISS
SEEING YOU EVERY DAY.
BUT YOU CANNOT SHAKE US.
>> SO, WE ARE IN FOR THE LONG
HAUL.
>> I WILL BE WATCHING YOU GUYS.
>> THE THING THAT SCARED ME THE
MOST, SHE HAS BEEN AT CNN SINCE
BEFORE THERE WERE CELLPHONES.
IN YOUR NUMBER CHANGES, I CAN'T
REACH YOU.
I WILL BE SO BUMMED OUT.
>> MY FIRST PHONE WAS A FLIP
PHONE FROM THE ASSIGNMENT DESK,
YOU KNOW, WHEN THEY WOULD PASS
OUT A PHONE.
>> THANK YOU.
ECHOING WHAT ERICA SAID AND
BERMAN, IN TRUE BERMAN FASHION.
THANK YOU FOR WELCOMING ME AS A
COVER REPORTER.
NEVER OPINION ON LIVE
TELEVISION.
I MET YOU, YOU WERE ABOUT 11
MONTHS PREGNANT WITH ANOTHER
11-POUND BABY.
>> YEP.
>> SKINNY AS EVER, THEN THERE IS
THE BABY.
I MEET YOU AT THIS AWARD DINNER
FOR FINANCIAL JOURNALISM.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> AND YOU IMMEDIATELY ARE SO
WARM.
YOU WELCOME ME TO SIT NEXT TO
YOU.
YOU SHOW ME THE ROPE ALL THESE
YEARS.
YOU ARE A GIFT TO US AND THIS
NETWORK.
>> OH, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU FOR ALL OF IT.
>> ALL THE FUN, ALL THE SMILES.
>> THANKS, EVERYBODY.
♪